ME.
>> IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK.
>> AND WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS
THIS MORNING, A SEISMIC SHIFT ON
ABORTION RIGHTS.
AS OF THIS MOMENT, ROE VERSUS
WADE ESSENTIALLY UP ENDED AT THE
STROKE OF MIDNIGHT THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE ABORTION LAW IN THE
COUNTRY WENT INTO EFFECT IN
TEXAS.
IT ESSENTIALLY BANS ALL
ABORTIONS AFTER SIX WEEKS.
SIX WEEKS BEFORE MOST WOMEN EVEN
KNOW THEY ARE PREGNANT.
NOW THIS LAW GIVES PRIVATE
CITIZENS THE RIGHT TO SUE
DOCTORS OR ANYONE ELSE CONNECTED
TO A WOMAN GETTING AN ABORTION
FOR AS MUCH AS $10,000.
ALL THEY NEED TO DO IS HELP.
IT COULD BE A LYFT DRIVER TO
TAKE A WOMAN TO A CLINIC WHO
COULD BE SUED.
THE TIMING ON THIS IS ONCE A
FETAL HEART BEAT IS DETECTED.
>> SO THIS LAW IS IN EFFECT FOR
NOW BECAUSE THE SUPREME COURT
DIDN'T ACT ON A REQUEST TO BLOCK
IT.
THROUGH THEIR INACTION, THE
JUSTICES LEFT THE TIGHTEST
ABORTION RESTRICTION SINCE ROE
VERSUS WADE TO BE ENFORCED.
AND THE LANDMARK DECISION ITSELF
COULD NOW BE IN JEOPARDY.
JOINING US TO TALK ABOUT ALL
THIS IS CNN CHIEF LEGAL ANALYST
JEFFREY TOOBIN.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE SUPREME
COURT HASN'T ENACTED ON THIS
YET?
>> THIS IS A PECULIAR SITUATION
DESIGNED TO CREATE LEGAL
COMPLICATIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE LAW BERMAN JUST
MENTIONED, IT IS NOT THE STATE
OF TEXAS THAT ENFORCES THE LAW
THE WAY IT WORKS IN MOST STATES.
THE WAY IT WORKS IN EVERY STATE.
IT'S THE SYSTEM OF PRIVATE
ENFORCEMENT, PRIVATE ATTORNEYS
GENERAL IT'S CALLED AND WHAT
THIS DIFFICULTY IT'S CREATED IS
THAT IT'S UNCLEAR WHO THE
ABORTION PROVIDER SHOULD SUE.
USUALLY YOU JUST SUE THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND THE COURT ISSUES
AN INJUNCTION ON STATE
GOVERNMENT DON'T ENFORCE THE
LAW.
WITH NO SINGLE ENFORCER OF THE
LAW, THERE IS THIS PROCEDURAL
PROBLEM THAT ABORTION PROVIDERS
HAVE THAT IT IS UNCLEAR WHO
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO SUE.
THAT'S WHAT'S CREATING THIS
LEGAL TANGLE SEPARATE FROM THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE ABORTION LAW BUT
THE EFFECT IS THAT THIS LAW IS
NOW IN EFFECT AND ROE V. WADE
ESSENTIALLY DOES NOT EXIST IN
THE STATE OF TEXAS AND PROBABLY
MORE IN STATES TO COME.
>> THERE IS SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
THAT'S FASCINATING BUT THIS LAST
SENTENCE FROM YOU, JEFF, PEOPLE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
AS OF NOW ROE VERSUS WADE
OVERTURNED ISN'T THE RIGHT WORD
BUT UP ENDED I THINK IS.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
JANUARY 23rd, 1973, THE DAY OF
ROE V. WADE WAS THE LAST TIME A
STATE HAD LAWS BANNING ABORTION.
TODAY, SEPTEMBER 1st, 2021, IS
THE FIRST DAY SINCE 1973 WHERE A
STATE HAS LEGALLY BANNED
ABORTION.
THERE ARE NO MORE ABORTION
CLINICS FUNCTIONING IN TEXAS.
ZERO.
>> SIX WEEKS.
IT'S VIABILITY, FETAL VIABILITY
WHICH IS ABOUT SIX WEEKS AND
SOME ESTIMATES THAT 85% IF NOT
HIGHER OF ABORTIONS IN TEXAS
TAKE PLACE AFTER THAT.
IT'S BEFORE MOST WOMEN EVEN KNOW
THEY'RE PREGNANT.
>> AND REMEMBER, IT'S NOT --
THAT'S THE LAW.
BUT THINK ABOUT WHAT AN ABORTION
PROVIDER HAS TO THINK ABOUT IN
LIGHT OF THIS LAW.
IF YOU ARE SUED, NOT ONLY --
SUED SUCCESSFULLY FOR AIDING AND
ABETTING AN ABORTION, THAT'S THE
TERM THAT'S USED IN THE LAW F
YOU'RE SUED SUCCESSFULLY, YOU
HAVE TO PAY THE $10,000 FINE,
YOU HAVE TO SHUT DOWN AND YOU
HAVE TO PAY THE ATTORNEY'S FEES
OF THE PLAINTIFF IN THE CASE.
WHOEVER THE PLAINTIFF MAY BE.
IT COULD BE SOMEBODY IN MONTANA
COULD BE THE PLAINTIFF.
IT COULD BE ANYONE IN THE
COUNTRY SUING TO STOP PEOPLE
FROM HAVING ABORTIONS.
SO, BEING RATIONAL ACTORS, THESE
ABORTION CLINICS ARE SAYING,
LOOK, WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO
THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT IS THE CLEAR PURPOSE OF
THE LAW.
>> OBVIOUSLY WHO IT WOULD
PREDOMINANTLY AFFECT ARE LOWER
INCOME WOMEN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CENTER FOR
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS SAYS NOW
PATIENTS ED V TO TRAVEL OUT OF
STATE THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC
TO RECEIVE CONSTITUTIONALLY
GUARANTEED HEALTHCARE.
>> THIS IS EXACTLY THE SAME
SITUATION AS IF ROE V. WADE HAD
BEEN OVERTURNED.
BECAUSE IF ROE V. WADE IS
OVERTURNED THAT MEANS IT WILL BE
UP TO EACH STATE.
SO, YOU KNOW, VIRTUALLY ALL THE
RED STATES WILL BAN ABORTION.
BUT, NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA, MANY
OTHER BLUE STATES WILL NOT BAN
ABORTIONS.
SO THE QUESTION WILL BE, IF YOU
WANT AN ABORTION IN A RED STATE,
CAN YOU SOMEHOW MAKE IT TO A
BLUE STATE?
DO YOU HAVE THE ECONOMIC
RESOURCES?
DO YOU HAVE THE TIME?
OR, CAN YOU GET WHAT'S CALLED A
MEDICAL ABORTION WHICH IS NOW --
WHICH IS -- AN INCREASING WAY
WOMEN ARE ABLE TO TERMINATE
THEIR PREGNANCIES THROUGH
MEDICATION.
BUT BELIEVE ME THE RED STATES
ARE DOING THEIR BEST TO BAN THAT
AGAIN.
>> THIS IS A ROAD MAP FOR HOW
THEY CAN DO IT WHICH IS WHY I
SAY AS OF THIS MOMENT 7:05
EASTERN TIME TODAY ROE VERSUS
WADE HAS BEEN UP ENDED IN TEXAS,
JEFFREY.
I'M CURIOUS BECAUSE THE SUPREME
COURT DID NOT STEP IN OVERNIGHT.
AND THEY COULD HAVE.
AND AS I SAID TO LAURA JARRETT
BEFORE, DOING NOTHING WAS DOING
SOMETHING HERE.
THIS IS A STATEMENT.
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO READ THIS
FROM THE SUPREME COURT
OVERNIGHT?
>> I THINK YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO
READ IT AS DOOM IS COMING FOR
ROE V. WADE.
NOW, ENTIRELY SEPARATE FROM THIS
TEXAS CASE, THERE IS A
MISSISSIPPI CASE IN THE
TRADITIONAL MANNER OF SUPREME
COURT CASES.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE FRANKLY
MANY OUTRAGEOUS THINGS ABOUT
WHAT'S GONE ON IN TEXAS HERE IS
THAT THE SUPREME COURT HAS ACTED
IN WHAT'S CALLED THE SHADOW
DOCKET.
THERE WAS NO FORMAL BRIEFING OF
THIS CASE.
THERE WAS NO ORAL ARGUMENT OF
ROE V. WADE IS SORT OF THROWN
OUT OF THE BACK OF THE CABOOSE
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF CEREMONY
HERE.
NOW, THERE WILL BE A CASE ABOUT
A MISSISSIPPI LAW THAT IS ALMOST
AS RESTRICTIVE AS ROE V. WADE --
AS THIS TEXAS LAW THAT WILL BE
ARGUED AFTER OCTOBER WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT -- NOW, THAT WILL
BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE SIX
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES YOU JUST
SAW ON THE SCREEN TO FORMALLY
END ROE V. WADE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT, THIS DECISION HAS THE
EFFECT OF ENDING ROE V. WADE
WITHOUT ACTUALLY PERFORMING THE
CEREMONIAL BURIAL.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR OPINION ON
WHAT HOUSE MINORITY LEADER SAID
OVERNIGHT THREATENING THESE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES THAT
HAVE GOTTEN REQUEST FROM THE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING JANUARY
6th SAYING ESSENTIALLY IF THEY
COMPLY, THEY HAVE HELL TO PAY
POTENTIALLY FOR REPUBLICANS TO
TAKE THE MAJORITY.
>> ONE OF THE THING YOU LEARN AS
AN ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY,
THESE TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES HAVE ENTIRE OFFICES
DEVOTED TO RESPONDING TO
SUBPOENAS.
IT IS COMPLETELY ROUTINE FOR
VERIZON AND COMPANY TO ANSWER
SUBPOENAS.
THE IDEA THAT THEY SOMEHOW HAVE
THE OBLIGATION, MUCH LESS THE
LEGAL RIGHT, TO SIMPLY SAY TO A
VALID SUBPOENA, WE'RE NOT
COMPLYING IS INCREDIBLE TO ME.
NOW, IT IS TRUE.
IT IS SOMEWHAT MORE UNUSUAL FOR
A CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE TO
SUBPOENA RECORDS THAN IT IS FOR
AN ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, BUT
IT STILL HAS HAPPENED BEFORE.
SO I REALLY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
LEGAL BASIS KEVIN McCARTHY HAS
TO MAKE THIS THREAT OTHER THAN
JUST BLUSTER BECAUSE PHONE
COMPANIES REPLY TO SUBPOENAS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
>> JEFFREY, GO BACK TO THE
SUPREME COURT FOR ONE SECOND
HERE BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT AND
WRITTEN ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME
HERE.
SUPREME COURT AND ABORTION HAS
BEEN VERY ANIMATING PERHAPS MORE
ANIMATING FOR CONSERVATIVES EVEN
THOUGH A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT ABORTION RIGHTS
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE FIRST
TRIMESTER.
WHAT IMPACT, IF THIS STICKS IN
TEXAS AND THIS SEISMIC SHIFT
HAPPENS WHICH AS OF RIGHT NOW IT
HAS HAPPENED.
WHAT IMPACT DO YOU THINK IT
MIGHT HAVE POLITICALLY?
COULD THAT ANIMATE DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS?
>> THIS HAS BEEN THE GREAT
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
DONALD TRUMP RAN FOR PRESIDENT
SAYING I WILL APPOINT JUSTICES
TO THE SUPREME COURT WHO WILL
VOTE TO OVERTURN ROE V. WADE.
HE HAS THREE APPOINTEES ON THE
COURT.
THERE ARE THREE OTHER APPOINTEES
ON THE COURT SAMUEL ALEE DOE,
CLARENCE THOMAS AND THOMAS HAVE
SPOKEN OUT ABOUT ROE V. WADE
BEFORE.
THERE ARE FIVE JUSTICES, THREE
TRUMP APPOINTEES PLUS THERE THEY
ARE ON THE SCREEN WHO SEEM LIKE
SOLID VOTES TO OVERTURN ROE V.
WADE.
WE HAVE BEEN ACCUSED THOSE OF US
SAYING THAT ROE IS ABOUT TO BE
OVERTURNED AS BEING CHICKEN
LITTLE THE SKY IS FALLING, THE
SKY IS FALLING.
WE'LL SEE.
IT CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE THE SKY
IS FALL NOING NOW.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN VERY UP
FRONT WHAT THEY WANT TO DO ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
THEY MAY DO IT AS OF NOW.
WE'LL SEE WHAT IF ANY POLITICAL
BLOW BACK THERE IS.
YOU KNOW, IT HAS CERTAINLY BEEN
MORE ANIMATING AND SUCCESSFUL
ISSUE FOR REPUBLICANS THAN FOR
DEMOCRATS, BUT AS STATES START
TO OUTRIGHT BAN ABORTION, MAYBE
THAT W